what the is going on I like to party
Jesus honey wax this is unwaxed get in
lizard we're going shopping with Sophia
and cine Salone did we just become best
friends
[Music]
y take it away Sophia
okay hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters Sophia and
cinee like the chapel okay thank you no
well every time um I was just saying
this but we were we were introducing
sine to someone recently and we were
saying how every times she says her name
no one pronounces it right
ever Christine 16
CC I mean I just sometimes I just make
up a fake name or I just say yes the
first time but I it just reminded me of
that really funny I remember we went to
Disneyland and this was at the time that
it's a small world was still I'm still
upset about this I know they shut it
down I think or they redid it but look I
haven't been in Disneyland enough so I
don't know if it's still there or not
but I think it shut down but when we
went they would ask you before you get
on the ride what your name is so that
the little characters could say your
name and so I remember cinee would
always say her name and she would say
she was this little thing and she was
like cinee sine sine and they still
every time we get on the boat and it
take us through and they go Kristen sine
knew cuz it would go Nicole Natalie
Kristen Sophia and those are our cousins
and cinee would just start crying theat
so upset also we'd go into the gift shop
I never had a keychain with my name on
it or I wanted one of those license
plates everyone had one with their name
on it never never never yours that's is
that why you changed is your name Tina
now is that why no Tina came from my
high school friends oh okay yeah because
mom when she screams at me she calls me
cistina have you ever ever just gone out
and not fixed your name for someone like
helped them out when they said your name
wrong yeah just leave it what was the
name someone called me uh well they call
me your name a lot and I don't correct
it everyone thinks that you are me and
I'm you we're one and the same I see
you're rocking fake freckles
today no no no own it I'm a big fake
Freckle girly wait why is that why are
you like you don't they could just not
know that I have fake freckles they
don't have to say that to people I think
it's so cute Scarlet still thinks that I
don't do mine well and mine look really
unrealistic yours are just yes I
actually do have to agree with her I'm
not going to lie I saw yours the other
day I think you did it yesterday and
they were just like very big and they
hold on yours look bigger than mine mine
don't like you can I like I think you
can kind of look in the thing it doesn't
look they're too perfect that's what's
wrong with yours I was going a little
random yours are kind of all over into
your that's the point just sit on the
little bow of your nose that's not
realistic I mean it makes your nose a
little cuter and smaller but I don't
know I said Scarlet Scarlet's like the
freckle police I think with that stuff
she's she literally uses that stuff
every single day every Trend that I've
gotten I've gotten from Scarlet yeah
she's so ahead of the times every time I
play a song I'm like Scarlet do you
think it's cool she taught me white
eyeliner she taught me how to line my
lips she knows everything I still I just
listen to topits I've realized that
that's I tried I have like my one like
not even this is not even Niche anymore
like 1975 was like my Niche thing that I
had or um I think it was oh God what is
the band's name now I'm forgetting the
band's name obviously they don't matter
to me that much but I would always
listen at top hits and now I feel so
lame cuz like you have kind of like cool
artists I've been trying to do that
lately and why don't you just ask for my
playlist because I want my own playlist
I want my own identi just accept that
you were one of the million that was
obsessed with Taylor Swift for no reason
wait for all I don't think that was a
hidden fact I think I've I know but that
to me was a fan that to me it's
like I want to say I get it but I don't
don't come for me don't come for me I
you know what it is I think she's a
great artist I'll tell you I'll tell you
why she's a great artist and why girls
really like her is because this's the
thing I wasn't a huge fan of her until
this last year when I had a breakup and
honestly when you listen to her lyrics
and you're going through something it
hits she's a great Lyricist and that's
what I think is thing makes people love
a great performer no doubt Sophia was oh
my god there was a period of time where
you would only describe scenarios with
one of her songs she be like sinee this
reminds me of your ex and then play a
song oh this reminds can I tell you
what's so ironic is the fact that when I
gave it to Scarlet she was like oh sis
Sophia describe my relationship using a
Taylor Swift song I did she loved I gave
her three she's like wow I'm adding this
on who was chirping on the side saying
hey Sophia give me my three I wanted to
see how accurate you were and I couldn't
relate I'm sorry she said she didn't
relate but I didn't relate because she
didn't listen to the lyrics Just like
how I try to explain but speaking of
relationships we all need to hear what
we've been dying to hear which is the
Halloween date The Haunted House date
you were literally talking about last
episode oh my God you guys okay last
week in the middle of the episode I get
a text from this guy sending me the
haunted house that we're going to as a
date I thought he was kidding cuz we
originally had just planned for dinner
so I thought he was just being silly
goofy boy yeah first of all we get
dinner it was so much fun what was fun
about the dinner this time that wasn't
so I've known him for I want to say a
year now he lives in a different state
we've only seen each other once before
but we've always kept in communication
he's a really nice guy he said I'm in
New York I'd love to get dinner and I
said sure I also went into it I'm not
gonna lie thinking we were just
friends because my brain didn't compute
like why would he want to start a
relationship with someone or date
someone if we're not even in the same
zip code you guys have kissed before why
would he go take you to dinner as a
friend that makes no sense you can't say
that counts I was drunk in a nightclub
that's not fair and then he's verbally
asked you to go out multiple times after
that so you going into as say this is
just a I'm the type of person where I
need someone to literally grab me by the
shoulders and say this is a date or I
like you because I will think it's any
other scenario I'm calling cop but okay
I found out very soon into this dinner
that it is a date and I was okay with it
I was like yes then what was the the
move or the verbal thing that he said
that was it wasn't anything that he said
I think it was just both of our
manorisms I felt really comfortable
there was a little bit of tension there
a lot of laughs the conversation didn't
lull I was like wow this has been such a
lovely evening and um the drinks were
flowing and towards the end of
dinner he goes I'm going to order us two
shots of tequila and I was like why
that's very ambitious for our first dat
it's a Wednesday you know what I mean
like what's the goal
here he's trying to loosen her up
that's well I said okay cuz I still have
an issue saying no but I said okay why
not it's a Wednesday and I said what is
this for after we took and he goes we're
going to the haunted house I [__] myself
I really did
because part of me really didn't want
to go just because I like scary movies I
don't want to be scared by actors you've
this is the first time I think I've ever
heard you say that you've always been
the biggest fan of anything that scares
you and now you're saying you don't want
to be scared is it because you didn't
know him you don't want to be scared
because I like being scared in the
comfort of my couch okay so on not in a
realistic setting no thank you I don't
want to be in the movie I want to watch
the movie yes so we walked to this
haunted house it was remind people what
it was called it's called blood Manor
and it's the scariest haunted house in
all of Manhattan conveniently it was a
7-minute walk from our apartment so I
was like okay that just is working out
too well also that's terrifying that
it's that close to our apartment point
exactly so we get to the haunted house I
said okay there's no backing out and
what I really enjoyed about this guy's
energy and and what he was saying he's
very much a why not let's go for it
what's the Worst That Could Happen live
a little kind of mentality and I feel
like I need that I need a guy that
brings me out of my shell pulls me out
of my comfort zone because I will never
be the person to take that spontaneous
trip or or go to a haunted house on a
Wednesday night just because it'll be a
fun memory I'll never do that he taught
me a lot which was really nice what was
that just things in just about like how
I should be and not that he was telling
me what I shouldn't should shouldn't be
doing but just
about so corny but the whole Life's Too
Short kind of thing and corny I think
that everyone can relate to that but
maybe I won't be that person but I
should definitely be with someone that
that's that's their personality no but I
don't think everyone is naturally a
person that is willing to step out of
their comfort zone I think that's what
you know differentiates people from one
person to the other because I would say
look I I'm a yes girl too I will if you
say like let's go to Mexico City
tomorrow and I have a great place and
this is going to be I'd be like 100% but
I'm not the person to initially do it
I'm not the book it I'm not the person
to think I'll go take myself to a museum
by myself that's probably the most
adventurous thing I'll do but you also
know that a tall tale sign that you like
someone is when they want to do
experiences with you for the first time
and those experiences are always fun
like I think you need to find someone
that you know you are going to enjoy
even though you're terrified of
skydiving or bungee jumping or riding on
the beach with a horse like it's a trust
thing like I trust that this person is
going to share a really good experience
with me and you and you just knew with
this guy specifically like after
especially probably this one that you
know you would have a really good time
with him regardless of the environment
so the haunted
house right as we're walking in were
greeted by two terrifying clowns that's
and instantly I said I wish lost me I
wish Sophia was
here that's a horrible thing to say so
badly Sophia was here I would have a
heart attack so I asked the clown I said
how long is the course he didn't answer
me he spoke in clown he was grunting
made no sense the other clown said it's
about 20 25 minutes so it's almost 2
miles of just haunted house you go in
from room to room each one has a
different set design sign there's about
seven scary actors that pop out in each
room I mean it's crazy you have to walk
down pitch black hallways and then
they're coming from the ceiling like it
was hysterical he was hiding behind who
okay I was he put me in front first
which I was like this won't work out
because I am not the person that should
be shielding you yeah red flag oh you
know what I also actually I don't blame
him I think he's a genius that's what I
would do to you it's actually so wow I
just remember this about a few months
ago I was talking to Mom about this and
I
said she's like okay well where would
you like to go on your first date oh my
God I cannot believe I forgot this and I
said honestly I'd love a guy to bring me
to a haunted house because because I
want to see if he'd protect me that will
show his character right there when
danger is coming at you how is he going
to
react and he put you for the first
second and then I shoved him in front I
said absolutely not and then you gone
okay but what was really funny and at
one point I was in a ball with him on
the floor I was peeing myself cuz I was
laughing so hard at the first jump I
screamed his name and I was like I'll
say it's Steve I was like Steve I hate
you I hate you I hate you I hate you
right and then all of the monsters like
walkie-talkie to each other throughout
the entire maze said this guy's name is
Steve so every room we' go into they'd
be like Steve that's gnarly I would
throw you under the bus too IID put you
first if that was my name was being
called
he freak out cuz he kept saying how do
you know my name how do you know my name
anyway it was so much fun um it was a
great great time but I don't really know
where that leaves us how do you feel
after the date like how do you feel
about oh dish it spill it say it do it
okay here's what's crazy I haven't and
I'm not saying I like this person so if
you're watching I don't like you but I'm
interested in you okay let's get that
clear I haven't liked someone in a
really long time I feel like I've gone
on so many dates and I've never left
being like I would see this person
tomorrow and then the next day and then
the next day I want to keep seeing them
I want to keep going to dinner with them
yeah and this is maybe it's the first
guy since my ex that I've really enjoyed
an evening with that's great but it's
been a bit it's been a a long minute
it's been a long minute I almost feel
like I for got what those initial
feelings are like again and I hate it do
you know what I mean yes like y I
haven't thought about anyone but myself
for over a year and now I wake up and
I'm
like is he going to text me is he going
to say good morning is he going to call
me today like I hate that now I'm
spitting again I know and it's so
annoying because I hate to admit that
when it comes to like love and
relationships it is the thing that
swarms your mind and you don't want to
but you're it's I don't know if it's
because it puts you in such a vulnerable
position and you it's the subconscious
constantly spinning your brain out for
no reason and he's probably just sitting
there eating a bag of potato chips no I
think guys feel the same way I think
they think about things and they you
know maybe not maybe not as intensely
like as we overthink the timing or
whatever but I do think that you know if
a guy likes a girl he's definitely he's
definitely strategic in some ways I mean
this is situational but I totally get it
because I've I mean look I was kind of
going the same thing you were going
through I mean if we if you know what we
were just talking about and it's just
like and it just exhausts you and if you
don't have to deal with it it just if
it's not worth if you really think about
how much of your day you spend thinking
about someone else that you don't even
know where their heads at I mean that is
what a waste of time that is but I'll
tell you what he did really correctly
and and this is maybe I don't I think he
did so many little things that I thought
okay this is why I like this person cuz
I haven't seen that in most of the guys
that I've been going on dates with MH of
course he did all the gentlemanly
opening the door you know pleases and
thank yous like just did all of that and
more yeah what I loved which most guys
don't do and I don't know why is that
same night right as he dropped me off at
my door right about 15 minutes minutes
later I didn't get a text I got a voice
note of him saying how much he enjoyed
the date how much he had the best time
with me how the next one is going to be
hard to one up just something to and
then he's like thank you for you know
spending a night with me it was amazing
and I was like you know what that's so
refreshing it's so nice and it takes two
seconds and it just makes your number go
up tenfold yeah I do think those little
things it's always the little things
like people think people Overlook it you
think that she won't notice when you
move her from the street to the sidewalk
or you you move her or you open the door
for her or you you know walk her home
just like it's it's so simple and these
little things are like oh she won't even
notice but it it's crazy and is that
sometimes us like asking for the bare
minimum and being so happy about it
that's what I'm also maybe it's because
we don't see it often that we're just so
in entranced when we do receive it yeah
if you're trying to court someone and
you want to be the guy or girl that that
person talks to their friends about the
next day do those little things the
texting the night of do not play it too
cool I hate like oh I don't want to text
her that night I'll do it the next day
or two days from now I want to play it
cool why that is the stuff that she'll
remember and like you even more for yeah
if yeah if you like her and you want to
make a move on her then you know I think
it's just all about energy I I don't
know I always you know I don't
understand people when they say oh I
don't like it when there's like too much
attention I'm like I think attention's
really I like to see some action here I
don't like to waste my time I I want to
see that like you had a good time with
me and you know there's a followup to
that you know something Switching gears
a little bit it's Thanksgiving week yes
we're officially in Fall mhm I'd like to
say we're getting into wife up
winter not ex far far from it people
actually you're closer to it but I'm far
from it we've actually been doing a lot
of really romantic dates you and I
recently you and I together we've been
doing a lot of couple stuff we have and
it's not like we've planned these things
we just kind of started to do it I mean
I I'll say this fall has been very
wholesome and it's so romantic and I can
totally understand when New Yorkers say
like come during the fall it's beautiful
it's this it's this and this and I go
okay you know I always went during the
winter but my God it is the air the
leaves then the the clothing the
everyone just seems so happy it's it's
like everyone's back from Summer and and
you know also let's just bring up
Christmas is right around the corner so
everyone's decorating the fall movies I
mean you can go from like When Harry Met
Sally to even like you know what we're
doing Harry Potter oh my God you know
what I'm actually really happy we're
doing this y I was so sick of being left
out of these conversations pertaining to
Harry Potter because Sumi I didn't watch
all of them in order like everyone else
did to so it I I watched like I think
Order of the Phoenix or something random
on a flight and so we were looking at
peacock and they just put all of them
out yes and so I was said oh we should
definitely watch them she goes yeah I
haven't seen all of them and I haven't
seen them in order are you kidding are
you under a rock she took the test and
she knows she's Slytherin but she
doesn't know anything about her house so
I had to we had to teach her so we are
literally on a Harry Potter marathon
which I love that I'm a Slytherin
because green looks really good on me so
it just looks good on me everything
makes sense so we've been doing a Harry
Potter marathon we went to the Harry
Potter store we well first we walked to
Bryant Park so they have like a winter
village over there and it is so
beautiful I mean there's little uh
little coffee shops and there's a ton of
dessert there's an ice skating ring like
first off it is date Central s and I are
probably the only friends there like
actually you say that now but while we
were walking through Bryant Park I said
quote
this place is really cool and special
but don't you think it would be even
more cool and special if you were here
with a guy and so was I you were like no
no I don't need a guy to have fun I
could be single and do this with you I'm
just as happy doing this with you that
out loud I didn't say like that you're
making me sound like I was a primadonna
there I said no you it was a totally
different context regardless when we
were walking back we first off got some
apple cider and then we had some pie pie
a stick
as we're walking back um we see cuz
we're in the midst of watching Harry
Potter the Giant Harry Potter
store so do you know what we did at 8:30
we walked inside and do what we did
there too we bought ourselves some two
mugs two coffee cups we put on all the
merch and we were running around like we
were 12 it was really it was we touched
every single wand and we're like hm I
don't know if snap's wand is for me H H
isn't for me either like who's who's fit
and so um we definitely got into the
spirit and then we went home and watched
it again and now we wake up every
morning with our Gryffindor and
Slytherin cup very wholesome of us I
know another thing that I would say is
kind of wholesome but not really is
you're doing sober November oh can I
talk about that I'm going to talk about
it anyways okay so she doesn't get it
cuz no one honestly is everyone's
confused every time I told someone I'm
doing sober November they go like you're
not doing sober January there's like
other months I did it too until last
Saturday I look I this is what I'm doing
and actually I'm doing a bunch of things
and I think that I'm really excited to
share with you guys how I've been
feeling the last 30 days after I've done
all these things because I'm not just
doing sober November which I actually
cannot recall the last time I did not
have a glass of wine for just one week
straight like I've had I don't drink
often I'm not someone that has you know
drink drinks five times a week but I
would say like at least once or twice a
week alcohol is included um and so I
decided after Halloween I go you know
what it'd be really nice to give my body
a break and I've never seen it's I I
sound like an alcoholic saying like I
haven't stopped drinking but no but I
think consecutively I haven't done 30
days of cold cut none I think I would
argue because we were in La we hardly
went out being in the most social city
in the country it feels like that's
pretty much how you meet up with people
oh let's meet for a drink oh you want to
meet up with his friend let's go get a
drink oh let's go to a bar like so you
drink way more in i' have like a glass
of wine when I'm making dinner or like
when I had my ex over we'd always have
like something to drink and I just don't
remember the last time in the last eight
months I just hadn't done it so I want
to dedicate 30 days of just cold turkey
like no drinking I'm still going out by
the way so that has been definitely very
interesting and I definitely want to tap
into that by the end of 30 days and talk
about what I've learned with social
settings the way people react when you
tell them you're not drinking in a
social and they're drinking why do you
have to tell them though well no if I'm
having a drink they ask like oh what are
you having and I say in front of my
girlfriends oh I'm not drinking it's
always like an audible gasp and I we
definitely like I want to have a longer
time to talk about this after but I'm
also not only just doing that because I
figured you know what if I'm going to be
on this whole wholesome train for 30
days I want to wake up and do meditation
for 15 minutes a day like once with
Abraham Hicks or Joe despenza like one
of those manifestation meditation no
idea who those people are but they B
it's just as a guided meditation for you
to visualize something and you know kind
of you are reminded about being gracious
and gratitude with the things that you
already have and being appreciative of
the environment you're living in the
fact that you have a bed and you have a
family or you have food on your plate or
you have friends or whatever it is just
to kind of bring you back to your Center
and then also doing daily affirmations
and I know this sounds really cheesy but
I yes I do look at myself in the mirror
and I just say like three positive
things about myself like I you do yeah
I've done it for the last so however
long it's been so far can you share what
one of yours today were yeah so I told
sisy this morning I woke up because I'll
say every day is not easy I'm not this
has not been something where I'm
suddenly instantly the last 5 days going
oh I've gone it you wake up sometimes
cranky tired anxious and so this morning
I woke up a little anxious because I
thought I wasn't good enough there's a
lot of things been on my mind lately and
so I looked at myself in the mirror and
I said okay what are three things I want
to say about about myself I said I am
compassionate like I love my friends
like I really care how they're doing and
I want to hear from them and I I am a
good listener with that stuff I am smart
enough to pursue the things I want to
pursue I am smart enough to you know
make it to the next step or you know
take those leaps that we've been wanting
to take and also I just said um like how
I love the body I'm in I'm like happy
who with who I am and I'm appreciative
that I have a beating heart and 10
fingers and tent toes and so it's just
things like that to kind of go okay like
you know you're good recenter yourself
yeah like at the end of the day you
think that a step toe is the worst thing
in the world but then you go but I'm
really not that bad like if you look at
a lot of the world like you're not in a
horrible place I think it's really hard
for us to get out of our heads and kind
of reenter and go you know worst things
can happen in life to us and you know
what we we all have our struggles and
some people have good some people have
bad but at the end of the day you know
I'm not saying that my struggles or any
less than yours or someone else's but I
do think that you know I can reframe my
mindset to going you know this is a part
of life this is probably a lesson there
is something coming from this there is
probably something I'm going to learn
from this or I give someone a lesson
from this and so at the end of the day I
am doing these three things and also
cutting out a little bit more gluten and
sugar just because my skin has been
acting up so that's another part of it
so I want to give after the 30 days like
what I felt in the last and see if
there's any transition but I will say so
far like definitely feeling some things
especially like physically I can see
maybe I should take a page out of your
book it's fun and you know what it is
it's also nice to have a goal for a
month and dedicate to it because I feel
like that you know people we have our
jobs and things we do every day but is
don't you isn't it nice to kind of go
throughout the day with a mental like a
task you know I am not going to do this
or I am going to do this or and it is by
the way it is hard for us to say no I
will say with the whole drinking and
stuff I was so tempted so tempted so
many times to just like go I'll have a
sip I'll just taste a little bit I'll do
this it's a crutch when you're in public
it's a crutch oh my God you have no idea
how often I was like God am I I'm not
addicted but like the fact that I was
just so I had that urge to do it I think
it's just when you're in a social
setting you feel comfortable I don't
even think it's the alcohol that you're
missing I think it's just the handt
mouth motion of having a drink in your
hand yeah if I you I would just fill
club soda up with some lime yeah I mean
like you could totally fake it but I
mean this can be a good transition to
something we wanted to talk about about
career-wise but I feel like the last few
months especially like going through you
know moving to a new city with an like
for finally being single again and then
also just there's other things in our
life that's going on I'm like you know
what I really want to restart in a
certain way like in this small kind of
way and just see you know how my mental
state is after doing this like what if
this is going to improve my physical
state cuz I want to just feel good
because I think if you feel good you
behave well and you you you feel like
you can accomplish more things like
you're more confident with yourself when
you physically feel like do you know
like when you're sick you're like
lethargic it's kind of one of those
rebalancing and res shifts in your
mindset and so I don't know I mean we
were talking about this last night with
our like career and I think that people
can relate to this yes we had a very
deep conversation over a burger and a
milkshake to straws which totally goes
against your no gluten no sugar thing
we've come to the conclusion that I am
the one that loves to dip the fries and
the milkshakes and C that is just
disgusting I'm sorry no it's not that's
disgusting the contrast of hot to cold
like it's just it's sweet and salty it's
not that hot to cold no no no no but it
was uh frustrating because I think for a
long
time I would say maybe this year the
most being 25 launching ourselves into a
new city trying to stay afloat it feels
like all the time with with friendships
and workwise and everyone always says
that being in your 20s is the best it's
the best time of your life and you this
is the part where you get to live and
make mistakes and be silly and run
amongst but Sophia and I have never been
those types of people where we're okay
with just existing in the moment like we
need something that fulfills us that
gets us up every day something that we
know we're working towards this end goal
and
right now it seems like I'm My Own Worst
Enemy I make up so many scenarios in my
head like my brain is always on
overdrive I can't sleep I make up about
50 to 100 a day where i'm just
overthinking stressed having imposter
syndrome and I guarantee 90% of the
things that I'm stressed about aren't
even going to happen yeah they're not
going to happen right and I always
question like why is it that I put so
much pressure on myself to be somewhere
at a certain age like why won't I be
able to find My Success at 35 or 40 why
do I have to feel like by the time I'm
30 I need to be financially secure for
the rest of my life have a routine down
have a full-blown business have
employees why because it's the
perception of social media and I think
this is something that people maybe
you're in like hearing is that you look
at us online specifically stina and I
and you think like oh you know they look
like they've got their lives together
everything is perfect the hair you know
you guys everything is so fabricated
with those 400 photos we take WE Post
one and I think that that's the hard
part is like being in this specific
industry it's a lot of young success and
I and it's a very rare but young success
that people have with their with their
careers they do something extreme online
and they make they monetize it and you
know I think that you and I you were and
are great in school you were always
someone that if you were given a job or
a task you've always EX did it well I
love homework she loved and I did too if
someone told us to do something like we
have to have this memo up or whatever it
is we will get it done tenfold like we
were I we were raised like that and I
think that being you know independent
and also we are entrepreneurs we're
we're a lot of the money and things we
do it's you know through ourselves if we
don't do it we don't make it and so you
know I think it's hard not having like a
consistency we're trying to also compare
ourselves to all these people that have
done it figured it out you know I think
um I'm not speaking for you but for
me I think a lot of
the validation that I get is through
other people so I don't think I'm doing
a good job until someone tells me you
did a good job or I don't think
I'm taking the right steps until someone
says no you're actually going on the
right path and when I don't hear that
I'm constantly self-doubting myself yeah
I know where I want to be and I know
what I want to do in five years but I
I'm always
questioning will I actually get there is
it a waste of time should I have a plan
B C D and I'm trying right now really
hard because I think it is important to
have these conversations because in a
way I'm hoping it'll light a fire under
my ass and just throw myself into it and
not worry so much of feeling rejected or
embarrassed to put myself out there or
not telling myself you shouldn't go for
it right now I'm trying to convince
myself no you are that the frustration
that I'm constantly
feeling is going to turn into success
like I'm hoping that the struggle will
become my strength yeah I think I think
there's that huge misconception that as
you said in the beginning um was that
your 20s are supposed to be like the
most fun the most crazy the best time of
your life and you know every adult tells
you that to like really enjoy these
which you should and you you I mean at
this point this is the only time in your
life that you are able to be a little
self selfish is what you said the other
podcast ago but it's also the biggest
and hardest and darkest struggles of
your life because you are building for
the future and so I was saying this to
scene actually on the way here because I
feel the same way too is that if you are
feeling like this everything that you're
doing now if you are let's just say like
for me specifically um my whole life
I've been a reader and I've read and I
read and I read and I never thought that
was going to go everywhere but all of
those times that I felt alone and I was
forced to read and I was like how am I
ever going to get out of this it
developed into what I'm passionate today
like with writing and having a book club
and so I think that you have to think of
it as a way of okay there is going to be
an end at the light of the tunnel with
everything that you're doing now that
all of these 20s and struggles and you
know the push back that you get cuz you
know when you're in your 20s also I feel
like there's a lot of rejections because
of your age there's a lot of rejections
because of your you know your youth with
not having you know the professionalism
of someone that is 40 or 30 years older
um and so it's just it's kind of just
having to remind yourself like everyone
is in the same boat as you everyone is
trying to figure it out everyone's
trying to find their partner everyone's
trying to figure out their career yeah
and it doesn't work overnight like
unless you're just you become viral
famous one day and that's not even
sustainable either but I totally also
understand when you're saying that you
need the validation from other people
because I'm the same exact way and I
hate it if someone says but not even
from Friends really I think I
really want it from my parents and I
think because they're so wildly
successful and my mom is a massive
business woman and my dad is you know
fly yeah we almost feel this need to
okay how there's no way I'm going to be
able to amount to that level of Fame
that he has right but how am I going to
create something build something on my
own that'll be just big enough for them
to say wow we raised good kids and I
think that that's been something I've
I've I mean if anyone can relate to you
it's me because I feel like you and I
have this you know little internal
pressure that we put on ourselves is
that how can we make them proud this
life that they've given us how do we pay
it back how do we return it I know maybe
maybe we are thinking that it takes us
having an empire for them to go oh we're
proud they're proud of us don't get me
wrong they are proud of us we I think
we've turned out pretty good but I think
that on another hand us as we're getting
to become adults we want to make them
proud as adults not just as you know
individuals we want to make them proud
as working succeeding adults whatever
that is whatever form that is but I just
the 20s the 20s
a they they pain apart I will say that
they're they're not easy all time always
Christ it's tough I always tell people I
can't wait till I'm 30 and people are
flabbergasted when I say that 1 I'm
Going on 30 I really am I don't know why
but I feel like when you're 30 you just
stop giving a [__] so much you're so
self-conscious when you're in your 20s
and you care so much about people think
and like you're worried about your
relationship status I feel like when
you're 30 you just start having a little
more fun I think you start giving less
of an f about things I mean I'm just two
years older than you and we were just
saying this I can feel myself starting
to become a person where I just want to
be in my perfect environment like I
think that when you're in your 20s
you're pushing yourself to be in all
these crazy environments or these
moments which is good I think that
taking the leap on things and traveling
and going and moving and taking that job
you didn't think you were going to take
and dating that guy you shouldn't date
all great learning lessons and all
growing situations but as you start
entering your late 20s like for me
specifically I can just feel and you
actually you can feel this too you just
in you're you're 25 that you just I'm
starting to just want to be in the place
that's going to make me happy for me I
love calm environments with a lot of
trees a dog and a book like that's
honestly my happy place and being in you
know in the city it's a little chaotic
and I don't feel like I am myself and so
I feel like maybe if I put myself in the
environment and like this is how you
feel too putting yourself in the
environment surrounded by the people
that you feel like are most relatable to
you where you feel like you can grow and
you know feel the most at peace with
yourself so you can confidently go into
things without you know feeling
overwhelmed with a lot of external
pressures that's really just a a good
way to you know I guess Thrive a little
bit more in life and so that's why I'm
I'm kind of at this place where I'm
starting to redirect and soal sustain
our mindsets we're thinking about like
even next year like what are we going to
do for you know living situations like
we both want to live in two different
places it's going to be very very
interesting couple months so stay tuned
to that one day at a time one day at a
goddamn time my brain hurts honestly
after that topic after oh I do want to
say something I had a really wholesome
night the other night oh what was it
okay so right now I am also on a
friendship Journey I've never been one
to have tons of friends yeah and moving
to New York especially
I've had somewhat of a roller coaster
experience in the friendships that I've
had and the ones that I'm trying to make
and it's really really really hard for
me to not click with someone because I
can really get along with anyone but for
someone to like me I always feel like
people don't like me so stupid 25 brain
I I feel like people don't like me so
anyway I started um really putting
myself out there cuz I never reach out
to people and I said I'm not going to do
that anymore because a friend isn't
going to land on my doorstep I really
have to go and try yeah and so I've been
hanging out with this girl a lot and I
was like let's do something really fun
like I went to Color Me mind I picked up
some pots and and um mugs and we went to
her apartment we painted them on the
floor and her roommates were there it
was so much fun and I got this text the
that same day from her just saying how
much she is happy that we've met and
that she appreciates me as a friend and
and literally I wanted to cry cuz I feel
like I haven't
felt that from a friend cuz like you
have your friends and Scarlett has their
friends and I've always used your
friends as my friends but I feel like
I've never had your own friend right or
had that girlfriend to call after a date
or if I had a bad day or if I had a
great day like I never had that person
and I feel like I'm finding that with
this person and it just makes me so
happy cuz I was like is it me am I
problem you know what's so you know what
it is this is not a talked about Topic
at all which is the struggles of making
friends because truly like you can't you
are not the only person in the world
that has left College went to a
different place and had to restart their
life completely like you've also had to
you know restart a couple times because
of you've moved to New York you went
back to LA you went to New York you've
been on the go and so it's I mean scarl
and I we've had like the four years you
know develop something with people and
that's what's sustained but like not
everyone has that that luxury not
everyone has that luxury and I think
it's so tough to find a genuine
friendship because I feel like people
especially as they get older are less
likely to open their bubble I feel like
people when it comes to making bubble
gets very small very small and it's a
hard pop not only does the bubble get
smaller you start kicking people out of
the bubble yeah and you start realizing
and I'm kind of going through this
Epiphany right
now a lot of the friendships that I once
had they're not serving me in the way
that I'd like mhm I think people
definitely grow apart and and
personalities change and they're on
their Journey I'm online but sometimes I
think you don't really realize how bad a
friendship is until you admit it to
yourself I think for a long time I was
just almost denying that the way that
certain friends were treating me
especially in Social settings was okay
because maybe I was just too embarrassed
to admit that I would call these people
my friends and they would still treat me
badly and you also didn't want to be
home talk about me you were like I don't
want to well I didn't want to be that
girl with no friends no I told but you
you're not she does have a few friends
but I it it's hard to make a best friend
it's really hard to find it's like you
can have a lot of friends but you know
the quality of the friend is very
different from each person like you
everyone's size you have a different
friend for a different thing yeah you
have your friend for going out you have
your friend for like deep talks you have
your you know what it is called it's
like finding your sister it's like
finding your sister that's not blood and
that's that is like the hardest thing in
the world and it it doesn't by the way
and I want to say it does not just it
doesn't take time cuz I've met people
within the last three years that I've
known less time than people I've I would
call my best friends for 12 years that
I'm the closest with now and I'm like
you are for sure going to be my
bridesmaid you are for sure going to be
my my my that was a crazy question I I
said to Sophia the other day I said you
probably have a good idea of who you
want standing up at the altar with you
right I said I have no idea and that's
sad so long a lot of people story short
though I'm feeling so good about this
friendship and I'm so happy in the
direction that it's going and I'm just
like Bliss I'm more excited about this
than like any guy honestly when she came
back from her date versus like her
friendship date she was way more happy
about the friend she's like this is so
much fun all the friends were so great
and I was so happy to hear that cuz I'm
like God she [__] deser deserves it
like finally thank you
you switching up to to make it more
light-hearted um I did something so so
toxic the other day what with this guy
as bad as what I've been doing
lately wait but okay
um sort of going back to what I was
saying that you start to overthink
things when you first see a guy that you
sort of like and you always are trying
to do things to get their attention like
maybe your posting in your story more
maybe you're yes playing hard to get
whatever it is right so um Scarlet's
boyfriend Louie we love him we love him
love you he sent flowers to our
apartment the other week very polite
very kind yeah as a thank you for
something it was so sweet only we knew
that they were from Scarlet's boyfriend
no one else so I may or may not have
made it look like uh mystery man had
sent me personally the flowers she
posted it on her story and get this it
worked he called me no yep oh girl
that's like you know you know that trick
where people say that you're at a a
restaurant and you go to the bartender
like hey send me a shot and say it's
from the guy across the room but like
don't point out exactly who it is that
is literally the same thing genius that
genius that's a hack if you want to get
guys attention pretend you got flowers
for actually hold on I have to find this
I found the fun funniest article sort of
relating to this on The Daily Mail the
other day oh here it is where we get all
of our news oh my God you guys this guy
Legend he is arrested now for this
though oh boyfriend who dated 35 women
and told each one he had a different
birthday so he regularly received gifts
is arrested for fraud in Japan I'm
sorry that is so funny it's kind of a
genius hack he told them all it just so
we got 35 gifts all the time that's so
awesome imagine every month expect new
gift he's a bad guy for that cuz he's a
liar and oh he probably did got fraud D
I definitely got like two presents a or
three presents a month I know but like
kind of Genius but a bad guy but kind of
smart I'm not going to lie I would be so
excited for every month I'd be like Oh
I'm getting two presents from two
different CES I mean how funny is that
like getting arrested obviously there's
something going on other than that
that's so funny I've never heard of that
before in my life I know I mean we've
all said little White Lies and
relationships we've all done little
things here and there here and there the
the flower one is an innocent one
harmless harmless harmless tasteful
actually harmless and you know I didn't
even write anything I just put a little
blushing Emoji like you're so you're so
so so so so so good okay to wrap up
this very interesting episode I did not
think we were going to go on this
journey together today can I say I
freaking love this episode because I no
I'll tell you why because I think a lot
of our episodes are very goofy and
they're very silly and we are that's who
we are half the time we are like that
but honestly I think truly we are this
side you know what not even half the
time I'd say This Is Us 80% of the time
and then our goofy side is our 20% yes
and I want to show you guys that we you
know we do have some insights and we
want to be vulnerable we are un waxed
and so I I'm happy about this episode I
really like it I actually am unwaxed
because while you're doing
no alcohol November I'm doing No Shave
November so I'm really living up to our
brand sorry Sumi everyone do No Shave
November next week we'll give a little
preview of what I really want to talk
about we're going to aay for a few days
oh yeah sopia is going to be giving an
incredibly sentimental and brave speech
for Children's Hospital foundation and
I'm so proud of her and I cannot wait to
hear the speech maybe we'll let them
hear it too yeah maybe I can read it but
let's just say also I have a fear of
public speaking so me thinking about it
is giving me knots to my stomach you're
going to do fantastic you'll be giving I
can't even drink I can't call the nurse
listen you'll be giving a speech about
your heart and I'll probably be reshing
mine because I'm considering seeing my
ex okay I hope you guys had an amazing
week thank you so much for tuning into
to this week's episode remember
subscribe to Spotify Apple podcast we're
going to start doing listener questions
leave your question in the ratings and
review section give us those five stars
and Happy Thanksgiving everyone Happy
Thanksgiving thankful for all the
unboxers we love you guys we'll see you
next Tuesday bye